welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for andorra coming to disney
plus starring diego luna as cassian
andor future spy for the rebel alliance
who meets his end in rogue one but right
now there is so much story to tell i'm
gonna break down this trailer frame by
frame for all the cool details that you
might have missed let's dive into it
[Music]
the trailer opens with a man the closed
captioning calls the time grappler which
is an awesome job title i want to be
known as oh that guy he grapples time he
uses a pair of hammers to bang on this
metallic bell the hammers reminded me of
the armorer's tools in the mandalorian
in the book of boba fett making me
wonder if this bell could be made of
bescar it actually has the same dark
gray color with the streaks of black in
it this would be a massive chunk of the
bhaskar something that the imps might
have stolen during their sieges of
mandalore if you look closely at that
bell i like how it's just one big flat
piece folded and bent inward several
times so that no part of itself touches
another allowing it to produce this
hollow clang sound now this andor series
will be 12 episodes the first two coming
out august 31st and set in the five
years of the rebellion before rogue one
a second season of another 12 episodes
is actually gonna be shot in november
and series creator tony gilroy said the
final scene will walk us right into
rogue one the cast and crew told vanity
fair that andor will be a refugee story
that begins with the destruction of
cassian's home world and then move on to
a new planet that gets colonized and
radicalized by the empire in this first
season i'm assuming this bell tower is
on a second of those worlds the time
grappler ringing the spell to keep
society taken along to imperial time
notice that one of the home lights
flickers on behind him so it's likely
dusk maybe the bell signaling curfew is
in effect moving on
okay we hear some deep bass throats
singing the kind of mongolian vocals we
heard in the mandalorian season two and
how jedi fall in order feature the music
of the who the other who eats you you
know i assume this is cassian's native
home world the one that gets destroyed
and this kid in the front at the
riverbed is a young cassian they see
this crashing ship of her head now based
on andrew's age in rogue one this would
probably be a clone wars conflict not an
imperial conquest yet next we see a
droid rolling through a scrap yard maybe
braca from falling order or the carthon
chop fields from mandalorian season two
in the background it looks like an
imperial star destroyer is being
constructed a while ago we saw concept
art of a venator-class star destroyer in
the shipyard that looks a lot like this
setting maybe a place where the empire
transitions republic crafts into
imperial ones and by the way thanks to
gamer oils for sponsoring this video
essential oils aromas for natural
wellness and healing but current
products aren't made for gamers now
there's a better way to holistically ah
just kidding this video is sponsored by
rage shadow legends get real raw and
epic with raid shadow legends and its
dark fantasy realism there is a ton
happening in raid this month with lots
of updates and tournaments raids
currently running a special event where
you can get your hands on the deliana a
brand new legendary champion from the
high elves faction all you have to do is
log in and play raid for seven days
between now and july 20th and you'll get
deliana for free she's a strong champion
it can help carry your team past many of
raid's tougher challenges this is the
best time to get started on raid and if
you click my link in the description or
scan my qr code you're on the screen you
will get a free starter pack worth
almost 40 dollars we are talking three
free champions at once misery cord tiger
soul romero plus 10 magic xp brews 10
force xp brews and 10 spirit brews they
only give us one champion to pass so
don't miss your last chance to get such
big rewards all this treasure will be
waiting for you right here and it's that
easy just click the link in the
description and i will see you in the
game the gifts keep coming all new
players listen up once you're in game
enter promo code my deliana to get your
hands on everything simple get 50 xp
brews to instantly get your legendary
hero deliana to max level 50 as well as
a ton of silver then what might be an
interior setting to this facility some
forced laborers building hardware and
assembly line part of a labor camp the
part they are working on actually looks
like the leg joint of the kx series
security droid that k2so was one of
cassian's missions may be to free these
laborers and this could be where he
finds and reprograms the k2so unit
before we see the two of them together
in rogue one on to the next clip
a rebel group led by cassian runs to
cover their blasters while another man
the closed captioning names salman pock
rings a different bell i just love the
contrasting bells of this trailer one
elaborate colonized bell to signal
oppression one ramshackle bell to signal
warning among the oppressed then we see
a few imperial lats low altitude assault
transports dropping in they approaching
that same shipyard that we saw before
now we see some of those shipyard
workers looking up and concerned onto
the next clip
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
here a woman opens her door to some
authorities now these are not imperial
but maybe there's some local authorities
who end up swearing allegiance to the
empire and carry out the imperial
bidding as a puppet government and my
favorite shot from this trailer shows
imperial officers which is such a sharp
contrast from the gritty naturalism of
the surface worlds leading this panel is
an officer played by anton lesser who
played qyburn in game of thrones with
his white uniform he may be part of the
same imperial security bureau of faction
that krennic was a part of in rogue one
two more imp officers smugly sip their
coffee while audrey arjona's rebel
character runs for it and next i'd love
the shot of what i assume is coruscant
from the street level elevator pods
descending while two more slide into
their place from the side coruscant
under imperial rule looks colder and
more militaristic than it did during the
republic era of the prequels i love that
transition moving on they're everywhere
they're watching me now
soon enough these days will end
so denise goff's imperial character
marches in flanked by death troopers and
then genevieve o'reilly returns to play
senator mon mothma after we saw her in
rogue one she originally played mon
mothma in revenge of the sith deleted
scenes it's the first time we've seen
these senatorial landing bays on
coruscant live action since revenge of
the sith rogue one showed coruscant only
in the background through a hazy window
we're gonna see mothma living that
double life as an active senator
gladhanding with imperial forces while
secretly working alongside bail organa
to deliver intel to the rebellion i love
how mothma's smile fades as she leaves
this fancy party obviously exhausted
from having to keep up this act then
some stunning landscape shots here while
some of the series was most likely shot
in that led powered volume unit that
you've heard so much about with all the
other star wars titles it looks as
though huge portions of this series
might have been shot on location stellen
skarsgard plays the rebel commander
named luthen who overlooks that shipyard
then there's a very very quick shot of
this lake with a number of massive
platforms if you look closely whirlpools
open along the sides of those platforms
suggesting these platforms may be rising
and lifting something from beneath if
you remember one of the planned
sequences for rogue one which tony
gilroy oversaw most of the reshoots of
would have shown the death star's
concave dish composite beam superlaser
lifting out of a lake and being lowered
into place on the death star that might
be what this scene is or at least that
dish still being under underwater
construction moving on
there will be no rules going forward
people are standing up
those forced laborers trudge back to
their barracks and then kyle solar's
character looks at a hollow projection
of cassian showing how he is already a
wanted man then we get this really cool
montage of all the characters from
behind the time grappler kyle solar's
character who is one of these local cops
mon mothma in the coruscant senate
chamber which you'll notice is mostly
empty evoking now any time you turn on
c-span you just see shots of the u.s
senate chamber with one senator speaking
and no one in their seats to listen or
to vote or to do anything then denise
scoff's character then another imp
watching as a tie fighter flies past and
then hooded cassian along this walkway
which is another image we saw in the
concept art then someone walking up
brandishing a wrench at a few clone
troopers phase two it looks like meaning
this could be another flashback to the
clone wars era before tarkin
decommissioned the clones in bad batch i
assume this is marva who we see at the
end of the trailer so let's move on to
that clip
that's what a reckoning sounds like
all right cassian hijacks a tie fighter
and jumps in light speed this is a
two-seater and then we end with marva
once more played by fiona shaw who is an
amazing actor whom you may know as
patonia dursley or her roles in killing
eve true blood and fleabag marvis seems
like an elder mentor figure to cassian
someone from luthen's generation former
separatist militant who hated republic
forces and has now been proven right as
those forces were corrupted into the
empire that's everything i spotted in
this trailer for android i am so excited
for this series we're gonna be covering
lots of stuff coming out of star wars
celebration this week we also got lots
of great coverage for the first two
episodes of obi-wan so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars follow me on
instagram twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars thank you so much for watching
goodbye
[Music]
you